>>> SO I GOT TO TELL YOU,
EVERYONE, WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM WHISTLE BLOWER FRANCIS IS
BLOWING UP FACEBOOK.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE TESTIFIES TO
THE BRITISH PARLIAMENT TODAY.
SHE SAYS IT ONLY TAKES A TINY
PERCENTAGE OF CONTENT THAT'S
HATEFUL TO HER WORDS HAVE A
REVOLUTION.
>> SO FACEBOOK COMES BACK AND
SAYS ONLY A TINY SLIVER OF
CONTENT ON OUR PLATFORM IS HATE
OR ONLY A TINY SLIVER IS
VIOLENCE, AND THEY CAN'T DETECT
IT WELL SO I DON'T KNOW IF I
TRUST THE NUMBERS BUT TWO, IT'S
HYPER CONCENTRATED IN 5% OF THE
POPULATION AND YOU ONLY NEED 3%
OF THE POPULATION ON THE STREETS
TO HAVE A REVOLUTION AND THAT'S
DANGEROUS.
>> HATE AND LIES THAT COULD
SPARK A REVOLUTION.
AND THE HATE THE LIES AND PLENTY
MORE ARE SPREADING LIKE WILDFIRE
ON FACEBOOK.
LISTEN, KNOWN IS SUGGESTING THAT
EVERYTHING YOU SEE ON FACEBOOK
IS HARMFUL.
NOBODY IS SUGGESTING THAT.
YOU MAY NEVER HAVE SEEN HATE OR
MISINFORMATION AT ALL, WELL, BUT
FOR PEOPLE WHO DO, THE ANGRY
RHETORIC IS LIKE A DRUG.
AND IT IS GOOD FOR FACEBOOK'S
BOTTOM LINE SO THE BIG QUESTION
TONIGHT WHAT FACEBOOK KNEW AND
WHAT THEY'RE DOING ABOUT IT.
ALL RIGHT?
IT'S ALL COMING OUT IN THE
FACEBOOK PAPERS.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS LEAKED BY
THAT WHISTLE BLOWER, DOCUMENTS
THAT GO REALLY DEEP INTO THE
COMPANY'S STRUGGLES TO REGULATE
HATE SPEECH AND MISINFORMATION
IN THE COUNTRY AND AROUND THE
WORLD, REALLY.
THE REDACTED VERSIONS WERE
OBTAINED BY CNN AND A GROUP OF
16 OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATIONS AND
WHAT ALL THIS TELLS US IS REALLY
CHILLING.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENS WITH GROUPS AND WITH
NETWORKS OF GROUPS IS THAT
PEOPLE SEE ECHO CHAMBERS THAT
CREATE SOCIAL NORMS.
SO IF I'M IN A GROUP THAT HAS
LOTS OF COVID MISINFORMATION AND
I SEE OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
IF SOMEONE GIVES COVID VACCINE
LIKE THINGS THEY ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED, THEY
GET COMPLETELY POUNCED UPON AND
TORN APART.
I LEARNED THAT CERTAIN IDEAS ARE
ACCEPTABLE AND UNACCEPTABLE.
WHEN THAT CONTEXT IS AROUND
HATE, YOU SEE A NORMALIZATION OF
HATE AND NORMALIZATION OF
DEHUMANIZING OTHERS AND LEADS TO
VIOLENT INCIDENTS.
>> LISTEN, THINK ABOUT THIS ANY
TIME YOU'VE BEEN ON ANY OF THOSE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS OR EVEN
VIDEO PLATFORMS AND YOU HAPPEN
UPON SOMETHING THAT IS, YOU
KNOW, WHATEVER YOU HAPPEN UPON.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT CLICKS
YOU TO THE NEXT ONE THAT IS
SIMILAR AND THE NEXT ONE THAT'S
SIMILAR.
IF YOU'RE ON A MISINFORMATION
WEBSITE, IT'S LIKE A RABBIT HOLE
YOU KEEP GOING DOWN.
IT DOESN'T GIVE YOU OTHER
THINGS.
IT DOESN'T DIVERSIFY WHAT YOU'RE
WATCHING AND IF IT SHOWS YOU
SOMETHING THAT'S A CONSPIRACY
THEORY AND SOMETHING THAT TELLS
THE TRUTH.
IT DOESN'T DO THAT.
YOU CONTINUE DOWN THE RABBIT
HOLE OF WHATEVER IT IS, WHATEVER
IS LIKE WHAT YOU CLICKED ON AND
THEN SOMETIMES I'LL GO ON AND IT
STARTS TO GET SCARIER AND
SCARIER AND SCARIER AND I'M LIKE
WHAT IS THIS?
IS THIS WHAT HAPPENS TO
EVERYONE?
THEY JUST SORT OF GET INTO THEIR
OWN MEDIA BUBBLE AND THEY'RE OWN
ECHO CHAMBER?
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
IF YOU GET STUCK IN THIS WHOLE
ECHO CHAMBER OF HATE AND
MISINFORMATION, IT IS
NORMALIZING HATE, BECOMES NORMAL
TO YOU BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT YOU
SEE.
A LOT OF CONANSPIRACY THEORIES D
RHETORIC TO INFECT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
THAT'S WHERE WE GOT TO WHERE WE
ARE NOW.
HOW DO YOU REACH PEOPLE THAT
FIRMLY BELIEVE THE QANON LIES,
THE LIES THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
THE ONE THAT LEFT WASHINGTON AND
DISGRACED NINE MONTHS AGO,
PEOPLE BELIEVE HE'S STILL
PRESIDENT.
>> WASN'T Q'S WHOLE THING TRUMP
WOULD BE REINSTATED AS
PRESIDENT?
>> HE NEVER LEFT.
THERE IS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND.
150,000%.
>> THAT HE'S STILL PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES?
REALLY?
DOES HE STILL HOLD THE POWERS OF
THE PRESIDENCY?
>> WELL, HE'S BEEN FLYING AROUND
THE WORLD ON AIR FORCE ONE, SAYS
SOMETHING.
>> I THOUGHT JOE BIDEN IS
TECHNICALLY ON AIR FORCE ONE.
SO THEY'RE FAKING IT?
>> IT'S NOT A PRESIDENCY.
>> WHO IS RUNNING THE COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> SO PRESIDENT TRUMP IS STILL
FLYING AROUND ON AIR FORCE ONE
IN HIS MIND.
PROBABLY THE MIND OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
HOW DO YOU REACH PEOPLE LIKE
THAT MAN IN THE VIDEO?
REACH PEOPLE WHO REFUSE TO TAKE
A LIFE SAVING VACCINE.
HOW DO YOU REACH THOSE PEOPLE
NOT THAT HE IS BUT HOW DO YOU
REACH PEOPLE THAT REFUSE TO TAKE
A LIFE SAVING VACCINE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC THAT KILLED
MORE THAN 730,000 AMERICANS.
>> NO, NOT GETTING THAT VACCINE.
NO, NO, NO.
THEM VACCINES ARE NOT GOOD, HUN.
>> ARE YOU VACCINATED?
>> NO, BUT I HAVE A LOT OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AT MY HOUSE.
>> HAVE YOU GOT YOUR VACCINE?
>> NO.
>> THEY AIN'T TESTED IT ENOUGH
FROM MY OPINION.
>> I DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT.
I DON'T TRUST THE CDC, I DON'T
TRUST NONE OF THEM.
>> DO YOU ANYBODY THAT GOT SICK
OR DIED?
>> I KNOW THREE PEOPLE THAT GOT
IT AND DIED BUT I KNOW PEOPLE
THAT GOT CANCER AND DIED, TOO.
>> YOU KNOW THREE PEOPLE THAT
DIED FROM CORONAVIRUS AND YOU
WON'T GET THE VACCINE?
>> NO, LIKE I SAID, I DON'T NEED
THE VACCINE.
>> HAVE YOU GUYS GOTTEN
VACCINATED?
>> NO.
WON'T DO IT.
>> CAN I ASK WHY YOU CHOSE NOT
TO?
>> I'M ALLERGIC TO A LOT OF
THINGS IN THE CHEMICALS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT AND FREEDOM.
YOU GET TO CHOOSE.
IF YOU CAN HAVE AN ABORTION AND
CHOOSE YOUR BODY, I SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CHOOSE IF I GET A SHOT.
>> AND THEN THERE IS -- I SAW AN
INTERVIEW WITH THIS MAN WHO SAID
THAT THE VACCINE WAS KILLING
PEOPLE AND EVERYONE WHO TOOK THE
VACCINE, RIGHT?
PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE IS GOING TO
DIE FROM TAKING THE VACCINE AND
THEN THE INTERVIEWER SAID WELL,
HOW -- WELL, THE VACCINE WAS
FACILITATED BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
HE TAKES CREDIT FOR IT.
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
HE SAID BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
SAVE LIVES.
HOW THEN DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
LIKE, IF IT'S DONALD TRUMP WITH
THE VACCINE, THEN IT'S TO SAVE
LIVES BUT IF IT'S NOT HIM, THEN
IT
IT'S KILLING PEOPLE.
SEE?
THE LIES, THE MISINFORMATION,
THE HATEFUL RHETORIC ARE
SPREADING OUT OF CONTROL,
REALLY.
EVEN THE HATE THAT SPARKED THE
DEADLY VIOLENCE IN
CHARLOT
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
JEWS ARE NOT REPLACE US.
JURY SELECTION IN THE CIVIL CASE
AGAINST THE ORGANIZERS BEGAN
TODAY AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
TONIGHT.
FROM CHARLOTTESVILLE TO JANUARY
66th TO VACCINE LIES AND THE
NATION DROWNING IN HATE AND
MISINFORMATION.
IT SEEMS LIKE AMERICA IS ANGRIER
THAN EVER AND FACEBOOK H